madame lafleur bonjour merci de nous
recevoir chez vous d'abord au nom de
toute l'équipe de radio canada nos
condoléances pour glisser
lise soeur de guy lafleur nous
condoléances également toute la famille
élargie
c'est triste de devoir enterrer un
garçon inséré première chose que j'ai
vue vous demander si vous le saviez
évidemment il était très malade mais ça
reste l'usure nanterrien j'ai un mandat
ce retrait la veille que j'ai été à
montréal le voit la dernière fois j'ai
demandé santé de venir ceci dit pour
piéger est exaucé oui mais j'étais plus
qu'un de vos frais non non moi je sais
plus capés d'avoir entre deux choses là
c'était votre garçon mais là vous le
voyez depuis une semaine mais tout le
monde les aime oui c'est comme si c'est
un membre de la famille ou le parti ça
vous touche de voir tous ces gens alors
qu'ils sont qui ont de la pénurie des
jeux tout cas payé tes était bien aimé
par le public
et public il y en a beaucoup votre
esprit nature so you
man qui tape le dîner d'ailleurs il
arrive à quelqu'un quelqu'un avec des
photos chandail facilier je t'interdis
je voyais en day lewis et corey qui
vient à terme il dérange c'est de be
safe et variées y un beso et généreux
l'avez vous déjà vu dire non à quelqu'un
non je n'ai vu parce que je pris donc
ils appartiennent actuellement puis sa
fille a pollué les eaux on voit défiler
là on est dimanche ça va être comme ça
jusqu'à demain soir et on regarde le
monde à montréal qui vont le voir ça
vous étendre ça vous fait quoi de voir
ben c'est mc thème ou 20 c'est
on savait que tu aimais mais c'est comme
imaginaire d'aboisso ses six gros c'est
comme s'ils appartenaient tous comme les
frères c'est que si il appartient à tout
le monde
aura c'est notre vie c'est comme si on
lui prêtait parce que on savait qu'ils
savaient qui rassemblait il dit lafleur
et rassemble les souverainistes les
indépendantistes les fédéralistes les
riches les peaux les gens toutes les
régions et rouge il avait le don de tout
le monde l'amour rassembler le mot et il
y en a plus beaucoup y en a pas beaucoup
des gens qui ont fait ça dans notre
histoire
c'était une exception in épices jeu
c'est pour ça que ça s'est fait tout
seul
qualitech alice métier que près les
demandes
je veux dire merci mme abandonner votre
appui votre enthousiasme et surtout
votre amour
mardi quand vous l'êtes à la cathédrale
marie reine du monde qu'est ce que vous
allez voir en disant voilà tranquille
qui y veille il représentait que fini
normal qu'ils aient scellé au jeu cet
été pique à peine digne ou non elle
s'ouvre sur béatrice ou qui souhaitent y
chaussettes au salon soit parce qu'on ne
serait pas lieu je voyais clio fait pas
dans mon cas j'ai dit c'est moi qui
avais dû partir maintenant van gogh oui
oui ben non mais c'est pas comme sur
saint-gilles loterie s'ils n'ont rien vu
c'est les j'allais donc avec vos
s'arrête là aussi mardy fish et oui ça
va dire
oui tu sais je sais pas comment ce qu'on
sam stress c'est de
devoir tout les de tous les hommages
puis qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
cathédrales c'est doit-il 20
nous serons alors merci beaucoup nous
allons aider